how low will it go Donald Trump's
approval rating has hit yet another
record low last week I told you that we
would need a few days to see a trump
approval rating number that reflects the
impact of the embarrassing failure to
repeal and replace the Affordable Care
Act we now have that data and it is not
good take a look at this you might
recall that about 10 days ago I
mentioned Trump's approval rating is
down to a record low for his presidency
of 37 percent okay that was around March
18th and this was also a record low for
any president 60 days into their
presidency if you're looking at the
graph along with me you'll notice that
Trump's approval rebounded to about 41
percent around March 24th but it has
since dropped again to another record
low for Trump
36% barely one third of Americans
approve of the job that Donald Trump is
doing again this graph is a three day
rolling average so there's not a huge
difference between 36 and 37 but the
important thing here is to look at the
trend line and the trend line is for
successively lower lows I've said it
before and I've said it again even
though the numbers are crumbling who are
the 36 percent of Americans that think
that Donald Trump is doing well what has
he done that you like do you even
understand what he's done or you maybe
just totally tuned out for a comparison
Pat for context on this 36 percent
number a 2012 National Geographic poll
found that 36 percent of Americans
believe in UFOs
so maybe 36 percent is actually really
low or does represent a sort of fringe
in society yeah and I also just wonder
if there was an event in the past week
or so that would cause his approval
rating to dip obviously there was the
failure of the Republican effort to
repeal Obamacare yeah but that really
goes to his leadership more so than his
ability to do his job I would say well
that's what makes it more these those
are the interesting questions looking
forward right your question is sort of
question 3 in my mind question 1 is what
is the absolute floor of Donald Trump
support I think it's around 15 to 20
percent of Americans that
we'll support him no matter what and
anything above that is people who at
least are open to saying I disapprove of
the job Trump is doing but 15 to 20
percent would mean a lot of people
admitting that they were wrong to vote
for him yes it would yes it would and I
believe that hey listen if if you're at
36 and you know whatever percent of what
was at 46 percent voted for him of
course 36 percent of all Americans
versus 46 percent of voters there could
be a lot of people who didn't vote at
all and disapprove of the job Trump is
doing but I believe that the base is
about 15 or 20 percent at what point do
Republicans jump ship okay I think that
if Trump's approval dips into the 20s
and stays there for several weeks you'll
start to see Republicans distance
themselves from Trump because of self
preservation and the upcoming 2018
midterms that's where I think the
Republicans jumping ship marker would be
yeah if the Russian investigation
continues to grow to a point where you
can't even argue the case of the
president anymore you're going to have
to jump ship at that point especially
because 2018 and 2020 are kind of come
around and if they tie themselves to the
president who went down and scandal yeah
that's not gonna be good for them oh
it's not gonna be good at all and then
lastly to get to sort of Pat's question
what specifically caused the decrease in
the approval rating what could raised
from sapru vil rating I don't know a
success on tax reform maybe some major
victory he can claim in the war on
terror and that's where I get back to my
story from Friday more Friday's show
where I said this would be the perfect
time for a concocted terrorist attack if
you believe in that type of thing
happening there would be no better time
because that's what would increase
Donald Trump's approval rating assuming
he didn't bungle it badly I don't think
they're that nefarious or especially
that competent really but it absolutely
would happen that his approval numbers
would bounce back up if there was some
major attack I don't did not I don't
have any doubt that there that nefarious
I think you may be right that they're
incompetent I think they would kill
American civilians not necessarily
American civilians no it wouldn't have
to be that but uh you know and by the
way Noam Chomsky two days
after I did that story Noam Chomsky said
watch out for a craft that are concocted
terrorists really interesting lead ophea
there's an article posted to our reddit
which by the way you can find at david
pakman.com slash re d di t we will take
a break and conclude my interview with
chip Brule next today's program is made
possible in part by Gamefly which is
sort of like netflix for video games
they've got over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can also stream games you don't even
need a gaming console or a computer
because you can stream games through
your Amazon fire stick or Roku box and
then use your mobile phone as the
controller you can play as many games as
you want for one monthly fee and if you
find some games you want to keep you can
buy them for a low used price never with
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a 30-day free trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included no contracts and you
can also stream the games I think I
mentioned that you can also rent games
through the mobile app get a free 30-day
trial for david pakman show viewers and
listeners and support our show at
Gamefly offer.com forward slash TDP s